vimos en el último vídeo que si tengo
una base [ __ ] normal vamos a partir como
en los últimos vídeos de una base [ __ ]
normal para un sub espacio bay si vamos
a escribirlo del psuv espacio ve que el
psuv espacio ve y si quiero hallar la
proyección queremos hallar la proyección
sobre sobre ese sube espacio ve de
cualquier vector x que se encuentre en
rn eso eso lo vimos ya en el vídeo
anterior esto se simplifica muchísimo a
simplemente multiplicar por a
transpuesta por el vector x donde pues
como siempre nuestra matriz a es aquella
matriz que tiene como columnas a b1 b2 y
así sucesivamente hasta de acá ok y
estos estos vectores son una base
digamos el [ __ ] normal corto normal
el espacio vectorial ve ok eso lo vimos
en el último vídeo y por eso es que nos
gustan mucho las bases [ __ ] normales
vamos vamos ahora a hacer esto con un
ejemplo concreto ok vamos a considerar
ve el espacio vectorial generado por dos
vectores de hecho ya lo hemos utilizado
en otros vídeos el vector un tercio dos
tercios y el vector y perdón la
coordenada dos tercios hasta aquí y
también por este otro vector que es el
dos tercios un tercio y menos dos
tercios o que entonces ya hemos visto
que estos dos vectores son cortos
ortogonales y que además tienen norma 1
sí sí sí no lo recuerdas puedes hacerlo
fácilmente calcular la norma de cada uno
de ellos y ver que son ortogonales entre
sí y vamos a ponerle el nombre de b1 y
b2 a estos vectores entonces sabemos
podemos concluir que ve uno el conjunto
que tiene a b1 y b2
es una base una base [ __ ] normal [ __ ]
normal de nuestro sub espacio be ok
entonces vamos a vamos a utilizar estos
dos vectores para calcular la matriz de
la transformación que es la proyección
sobre el espacio vectorial b ok entonces
lo que queremos hallar es la proyección
sobre el sub espacio b de cualquier
vector x ok entonces como vamos a hacer
esto esto sabemos que es si nos tomamos
la matriz a que tiene como columnas a
los vectores de la base entonces esta
matriz es la que tiene aquí un tercio
dos tercios
y dos tercios y acá vamos a tener dos
tercios un tercio y menos dos tercios ok
esta matriz es la que tiene como
columnas a la base y entonces la
proyección es aportar transpuesta x
entonces nos interesa calcular quien es
esta matriz
vamos a calcular a x a transpuesta ok
esto es lo que vamos a calcular y
entonces esto lo podemos poner como la
matriz
me ponerla bien está
hacerlo un poco más larga tenemos la
matriz a que es un tercio dos tercios
dos tercios acá va a ir dos tercios un
tercio menos dos tercios
muy bien y luego multiplicamos por la
matriz a transpuesta que simplemente es
es como a costar la verdad es esta
columna pasarla como renglón en esta
columna pasarla como renglón entonces
vamos a tener un tercio dos tercios dos
tercios
dos tercios aquí un tercio aquí y menos
dos tercios muy bien entonces esta
multiplicación es lo que nos va a dar la
matriz de transformación y no tenemos
que éste es de 3 por 2 y este es de 2
por 3 entonces me va a dar una matriz de
3 x 3
3 por 3 entonces vamos haciendo este
renglón por esta columna es bueno si se
dan cuenta todos tienen un tercio
entonces cuando yo multiplique aquí por
ejemplo el primero va a ser un tercio
por un tercio que es un 9º dos tercios
por dos tres y dos son cuatro novenos
todo va a llevar un noveno entonces ese
noveno lo voy a sacar muy bien entonces
tengo un tercio por un tercio es un
noveno que aquí está un noveno entonces
aquí va un
no todavía no va uno más dos tercios por
dos tercios son cuatro novenos con el 1
que ya llevaba son 5 y con el noveno
aquí afuera ya está ahora vamos este por
este y es un tercio por dos tercios son
dos novenos más dos tercios por un
tercio que son cuatro novenos entonces
aquí va el cuatro un tercio por dos
tercios son dos tercios dos tercios por
menos dos tercios son menos cuatro
tercios con los dos tercios que llevaba
son aquí menos dos muy bien esto fue con
este renglón ahora vamos con este otro
renglón aquí sería dos tercios por un
tercio son dos tercios más dos tercios
perdón perdón son dos tercios por un
tercio es dos novenos un tercio por dos
tercios son dos novenos entonces me
queda aquí un cuatro dos tercios por dos
tercios son cuatro novenos
un tercio por un tercio es un noveno que
son aquí en total cinco novenos dos
tercios por dos tercios son cuatro
novenos menos
o sería un tercio por menos dos tercios
son menos dos novenos eso nos quedan
simplemente dos novenos
no sé si anteriormente había dicho
novenos pero todos son novenos verdad
dos tercios por un tercio son dos
novenos menos dos tercios por dos
tercios son menos cuatro novenos
entonces aquí nos da menos dos de hecho
ya estamos usando este este renglón ya
nos vamos con este renglón y entonces
nos oyó menos dos aquí sería dos tercios
por dos tercios son cuatro novenos menos
dos tercios por un tercio es menos dos y
que al final nos da dos y finalmente es
dos tercios por dos tercios son cuatro
novenos menos dos tercios por menos dos
tercios son otros cuatro novenos y eso
nos da ocho entonces esta es la matriz
de transformación de una proyección de
cualquier vector en r3 sobre el sub
espacio b y es
mucho menos doloroso que las formas en
que lo hemos hecho anteriormente